- [Announcer] Have you ever
looked around and wondered,
"Where does all of my stuff come from?"
Maybe you have a pencil that
looks something like this.
Now, lots of different things
go into making a pencil,
but we can break it down
into a few basic parts.
For example,
the wood that makes up
the body of the pencil
comes from trees.
Most pencil erasers nowadays are made from
some kind of plastic,
which is refined from oil.
And this aluminum ring here
at the base of the pencil
and the graphite tip at
the top are both made
from different minerals.
Everything we use can be traced
back to natural resources,
which are things provided by
the Earth and its processes.
Some natural resources that we use a lot
in our day-to-day lives
are trees, fresh water,
minerals, and fossil fuels like oil.
We can divide these different
types of natural resources
into renewable resources
and nonrenewable resources.
Renewable resources can be replenished
in a relatively short amount of time.
Now, I say relatively
short because in some cases
it still might take quite a
few years for them to renew.
For example, if you have a
tree and you cut it down,
but you plant a new
tree to take its place,
you're still gonna have
to wait let's say 20 years
before you can have
another fully grown tree.
Nonrenewable resources
are often very limited
and can take much longer
than a human lifetime
for the earth to replenish them.
For example,
when carbon is compressed
for millions of years,
it can turn into a diamond.
Once we mine that
diamond out of the earth,
it'll take millions of
years for another diamond
to be formed that's the same size.
Now, just because a resource is renewable,
doesn't mean we can use as much
as we want whenever we want.
We know that trees are a
renewable resource, right?
However, cutting down too many trees,
a process called deforestation,
can have downsides.
Many animals rely on
trees for habitat or food.
And they can't exactly wait 20 years
for their homes to grow back.
Plus, taking wood out of
the ecosystem and burning it
releases extra carbon
dioxide that's gonna end up
in the atmosphere,
rather than naturally moving
through the carbon cycle.
This is one of many things
that contributes to climate change.
We also can't find all the
natural resources we need
in all of the places where we need them.
Different places have unique geographic
or geologic features,
like mountains and forests
or rivers and oceans.
So they all have different resources.
Since natural resources
aren't evenly distributed,
different regions trade, sell,
or exchange their
resources with each other.
For example,
let's say a community lives at the base
of these mountains here,
so they can chop down wood from the forest
whenever they need it.
If they go looking in the mountains,
they might even find some rare minerals.
Another community down the
road lives near the river,
so they can go fishing every day.
The soil near the river
is also really good
for growing crops.
So they farm a lot of tasty vegetables.
Now let's say the people
in the mountain community
want to eat the fish, pumpkins,
and other crops harvested
in the river community.
At the same time,
the river community wants
those hard to find minerals
and wood to make new farm tools.
They'll need to find a way to
share their unique resources
so everyone gets what they need.
Now try and imagine this
system on a global scale.
The things we rely on every day,
from the pencils that you use to write,
to the technologies that
power our communities,
they all connect us in some
way back to the resources
that our planet naturally provides.
Take a look around again.
Where in the world did
the things in your life
really come from?
Once you break an object
down to its original pieces,
you might be surprised by what you find.